[Music]
welcome to the QuickStart tutorial for
cloud functions we're going to see how
to deploy a cloud function from a Google
cloud project to start make sure you've
got a Google cloud project with building
enabled the first thing you'll want to
do is enable cloud functions API in the
navigation menu click on API and
services and click enable api's and
services here search for cloud functions
and select it from the results on the
cloud functions API page click enable to
enable it on the project next head to
cloud functions on navigation menu we'll
find this under the compute section
click here where it says create function
name your function whatever you'd like
for this demonstration we'll keep HTTP
selected as a trigger keep in line
editor selected for the source code as
we can see here cloud functions support
multiple runtimes for now we'll use
nodejs 8 by default we're provided with
a basic hello world function that will
respond to an HTTP request click on the
expanded editor window icon to get a
better look we won't have to make any
changes here so click OK
to go back here where it says function
to execute is where we would specify the
function in our source code that we'd
like to execute in this case HelloWorld
is the only one that we have and it's
the one that we want to execute click
create to deploy our cloud function the
cloud functions overview page will give
us a general overview of all of our
cloud functions including region trigger
run time and the time of its last
deployment as well as permissions once
it's done deploying click the menu of
our function and click test function on
the testing page we can test our
function by sending a triggering event
in JSON format our test function
responds to events by outputting the
value for a message so let's send it a
JSON object with a value 4 message click
on test the function and check out the
output
as we expected the function outputs the
message that we provided above down
below will see the log associated with
our function there are entries for when
the function execution started as well
as when the function finished along with
status code we can get an expanded view
of the logs by clicking here where it
says see all logs for this function
execution here we'll see the same log
entries along with a lot more
information should we need it and that's
all there is to it we've successfully
deployed a cloud function
[Music]